[Musique]
cette semaine dans notre chronique
juniors on s'intéresse aux plus petits à
magny les hameaux un espace leur est
entièrement dédiée les détails avec
mélanie poté bonjour mais la vie bonjour
camille ça s'appelle même sow cocoon
c'est un espace sensoriel spécialement
destinée aux enfants de six semaines
jusqu'à deux ans et demi il est touché
il a été créé par dont il ya cinq ans
par une artiste plasticienne soko
écoutez là c'est vraiment parti d'une
envie personnelle de créer quelque chose
pour le tout petit alors de par mon
expérience et aussi de maman à un moment
donné et puis surtout voilà j'ai envie
de dire j'avais vraiment envie de de
proposer quelque chose autour du non
verbal et c'était avant tout pour faire
plaisir
et voilà qu'un magicien et c'est devenu
quelque chose qui est devenu un lieu qui
accueille du public
donc ce lieu est ce qu'on peut dire que
c'est un parcours mélanie alors pas du
tout ce qu elle insiste même sur le
terme espace il ya un tunnel il ya des
petits tipis et des petits oursons avec
lesquels les petits peuvent jouer tous
les éléments ont été confectionnés à la
main avec des matériaux doux alors de
différentes matières il ya la peau nous
ton du velours côtelé de la pub même de
la ouate
c'est très orienté sur le toucher mais
tous les sens sont consternés et les
enfants peuvent faire ce qu'ils veulent
les enfants malheureusement ne peuvent
pas en témoigne 6 ans trop petit mais on
voit qu'il ya une grande liberté chez
eux puisque les consignes de départ que
je donne aux parents c'est que tout
était tout et secure et de fait les
enfants sont libres
il n'y a pas d'interdît c'est rare et
les endroits où on peut toucher à tout
expérimenté jusqu'au bout voilà ça c'est
vraiment je pense ce qui ce qui permet
aux enfants d'être libres de leurs
mouvements
et c'est aussi l'occasion de passer du
temps avec son enfant l'atelier dure
environ une trentaine de minutes et les
prix commencent à partir de 5 euros 50
il est animé par ce qu elle même alors
il reste que il reste deux créneaux ce
samedi à 10 heures et à 11 heures pour
découvrir l'espace s'étale estaminet de
mehdi les hameaux et toutes les
informations sont à retrouver sur le
site internet de la commune et le 21
janvier justement demain c'est la
journée mondiale du câlin donc
l'occasion de fêter ça en famille
pourquoi pas merci beaucoup à mélanie
entre que nous avoir présenté cet espace
sans qu'aucun